[Music]
please man let's talk about this we did
a good talk
[Music]
she's going I don't think he planned
this out and
again
he did just beat you so I'm not a
terrible Mentor you're both equally
terrible does that settle it
stop pretending you know where you're
going I have a plan I just haven't told
you yet
recording for the moon that's not good
foreign
[Music]
what's up man
everywhere you go you're an anomaly
you're the original anomaly
the spider that gave you gave you Powers
wasn't from your dimension
it was never supposed to bite you
there's a world out there with no
Spider-Man to protect them because if
it's you instead you're not supposed to
be Spider-Man no you're lying I'm
Spiderman you're a mistake
you hadn't been bit your Peter Parker
would have lived instead he died saving
you
you would have stopped the collider
before it ever went off spot wouldn't
exist and none of this would have
happened and all this time I have been
the only one holding it all together
you don't belong
s
isn't what we talked about
you talked about this
no
you all knew
I I didn't know
how to tell you
that's why you never came to see me
miles it's for your own good who decides
that
I'm not a kid
that's exactly what you are you're just
a kid there's no idea what he's doing
yeah well if I did wear hundreds of
spider people away from your little
clubhouse
I guess you did plan this out
and I'm about to do this
[Music]
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
backwards
I taught him how to do that so I gotta
be a pretty good Mentor pull that off
[Music]
nope no
that's not cute oh no
huh
hmm
foreign
thank you
[Music]
come on no no
no no no no
the machine activated on its own how is
that possible
how about this
you're getting in the way
[Music]
stop him now man what does it look like
I'm trying to do
something
oh
[Music]
oh okay enough it's not the console's
fault all he had to do was listen
why didn't he listen Maybe you weren't
hard enough on him when don't do it you
let him go
catch him okay let's all just take a
breath you want to back me up well okay
Miguel as a father of a daughter and the
son of a mother yeah actually stop
talking okay duly noted let me just talk
to him
try that he's my friend yeah and that's
the problem do you know for certain what
happens if he breaks the cannon
do you want to find out
I told you she was a liability
you're wrong
Jess tell him he's wrong
he's not are you serious right now I
told you you let him get away I can't
help you
I'm not coming you're right
what
the hell
[Music]
go home quick
we are supposed
[Music]
oh
you are
we are
Jess
[Music]
foreign